the holidays can be a time of
Celebration and a time of desperation
tonight more evidence of animal neglect
good evening to you I'm Brian Loftus and
I'm Denise Valdez
School Madison Kimbrough spoke to those
who fear the strain of inflation and the
holidays may cause more owners to dump
their pets it's a story you'll only see
on eight
it was here Saturday night that a mama
Pitbull and her three puppies were found
wandering the road and tonight we hear
from the two women who pulled over to
bring them to safety I looked over to my
right and I saw four loose dogs with a
somebody another car parked and I was
thinking well what is happening there
Sarah restori was on her way home
Saturday night when she saw four pit
bulls on the side of the road she would
soon realize it was a mama dog with her
three puppies left stranded in the cold
without food water or shelter I pulled
over and then I just determined that
like these dogs are absolutely dumped
this is a really dark area it's just a
desert there's no lighting there's no
homes here the mom dog came and gave me
gave me kisses yeah the the puppies were
shivering and they were super sweet
after three hours Metro showed up to
help with animal control taking over
after that nilu safai who helped Sarah
with the rescue says she's seen this
type of situation too many times while
driving around and wants people to be
vigilant and reported if they see
something like this occur people who do
that is just they have a heart of a
stone How could somebody
the least they can do they just go to
the shelter and say hey I found them
even if you don't want to tell them
that's yours so they found them then in
this cold weather leave them out here
without food and
they got hit by they might get hit by a
car safai not alone in her thinking as
eight news now reached out to the nspca
who confirmed that during the holidays
pet abandonment is high and Clark County
animal protection services confirming
with us that the four dogs found are now
under a 72-hour hold but will soon be up
for adoption if unclaimed and we reached
out to the animal foundation in hopes of
meeting the four pitbulls but were
unable to now again they are up for
adoption later this week and we'll be
sure to keep you updated on their
progress here on channel 8. reporting
near Twain and buffalo Madison Kimbrough
8 News Now